hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer I provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and today we're talking about
how to cram for a technical interview at
a top tech company in 10 days something
that I very recently had to do and be
comfortable with because I had exactly
10 days to cram for a coding interview
and I haven't touched DS or agles or
leode or none of it in four years so
when I say 10 days I'm not saying oh but
I've been prepping the last couple of
months or weeks but I really honed down
these no we're talking beginning to
finishing in 10 days so let's get into
it so the first stage here is gathering
information and the first step for that
stage is going on glass door and seeing
what other people have said about the
technical interview bonus points if you
can specify what role you're applying
for or interviewing for so for example
software engineer versus backend
engineer backend engineer is a lot more
specific so if we can see what other
people who have interviewed for backend
engineer have said about the technical
interview experience that'll be loads
better than software engineer but
sometimes we can't always get that
specific so software engineer is fine
see if people have shared the level of
the problem they received for example
lead code easy medium versus hard that's
typically the standard people will base
their ranking on is Le code now keep
that tab open and go to Fishbowl
Fishbowl was recently acquired by glass
door because it kind of does the same
thing provide a space where people can
talk about their experiences but not
just experien getting a job but also
experien at a job or wanting promotions
or certain hiring managers at certain
companies but we can Niche Fishbowl down
to see what people's interview
experiences were like another great
thing about Fishbowl is you can actually
directly ask these questions so you can
go into fishbowl like you would I don't
know threads or Twitter and write an
actual post saying hey does anyone have
experience with so and so company for so
and so job if so I would sincerely
appreciate you letting me know what type
of problems to prepare for so you can
ask a question and also see what other
people have said when they have asked a
similar question which someone likely
has once you have the data from those
two steps make sure you copy and paste
the relevant answers into your own
separate document where you can keep
track of what people said about the
technical interview adding All Those
Questions into that document is step
three and now step four is get into Le
code now here's
where the real work begins I highly
recommend and this is not sponsored by
anybody but you know somebody can you
know you can hit me up get Le code
premium I have never had Le code premium
until these 10 days where I've had to
study like crazy the specific reason I
got Le Cod premium was so I could study
per the company questions that have been
reported so let's say I'm interviewing
for I'll do an easy one meta people will
report what questions they were asked
during technical interviews and leak
code will gather that up and allow you
to practice on those questions this
makes studying so much easier because
now you don't have to guess what is
going to be given to you and you don't
have to just like wish for the best it's
like no this is what people have said
leod is saying people have been asked
and it also when you go to the company
specific questions page will show you
how frequently people reported being
asked a certain question so you can even
base your practice based off of How
likely you are to receive this question
at an interview well I guess that's not
technically How likely you are to
receive the question but it's more how
many people say they received it which
can be interpreted as How likely are you
but you know what I mean I'm not one to
get premium memberships when it comes to
professional Endeavors of mine I always
feel like I feel like there's a free
version of what I'm looking for but when
it comes to this I I feel like that just
isn't the case and so that is really why
I decided to commit and say you know
what let me get the premium now let me
put an asteris on that tip get premium
if your company is in that list of
available filters because maybe you're
applying
to I don't know glass door even though
it's a big company that many of us know
it may not be in the list of companies
available for Leo specific problem step
five now once you have those companies
available to you go into that company
page and filter not based on frequency
asked but on acceptance because again
likely we have not touched leode in a
hot minute or for some reason we need to
just jam-pack our studying into only a
couple of days and so when you rank
based on the number of times people have
said they received that problem you have
a high likelihood of the problems being
maybe more challenging and instead we
want to work our way up to those
problems so I suggest ranking based on
acceptance ranking based on acceptance
is ranking in accordance to how many
people were able to submit a right
answer to that which can kind of be
interpreted not as easier to hardest
because that is a level but more like
just capability your likelihood of being
able to answer this question that's how
I've always interpreted it and when you
rank based on acceptance you'll see that
there is a big correlation between a
high acceptance level and it being an
easier problem more on that remember the
document we created see what level lead
code problem most people reported having
so for the company I'm interviewing for
everywhere I've seen people have said Le
code medium and including the recruiter
the recruiter herself said expect aot
code medium so even while I'm ranking by
exceptions I'm focusing on leode medium
so as I go through the problems and I
get better and better at them as the
days go by I don't think I'm really
going to switch over too hard because it
doesn't seem like there's a point to it
and we're trying to be as efficient and
smart about the study plan as possible
now it's okay that you don't know how to
solve these problems yet because step
six is see how they are solved open up a
problem read through it and see how you
yourself a capable human being would
solve that problem not in terms of code
or algorithms or anything just you
yourself looking at this problem so for
example a common problem is sorting an
array me myself is someone came up to me
just on the street saying hey can you
sort this array I know my process as a
human being I would look at the array I
would look at each number and I would
see is this number less than or greater
than or equal to this other number and I
do that over and over again until I go
through the entire list and then boom
the array is sorted
now that you have processed how you as a
human being would solve this problem now
think about a computer a computer needs
very specific instructions write down
step by step in your code but comment it
out what you're doing to process the
problem as a human then follow that up
with whever you can fill it in with code
so for example with the previous problem
of of sorting the array sorting the list
I said okay if this number is less than
this number then place it here instead
of there in that statement I said if I
said less than those are some very
specific ways to solve problems in
programming there are if statements
there are comparisons all the works and
so what I'm trying to say is once you
write down how you yourself would solve
that problem see where you can place
actual code in place of of your pseudo
code because that's what you did you
wrote some pseudo code when you can't
fill in the pseudo code with real code
anymore go look up the answer using chat
GPT or YouTube and honestly it's more of
an and or YouTube because I've been
using both a lot because chat is amazing
for explaining things but sometimes I
can't visualize the solution and so
that's where I'll go to YouTube to truly
get that visualization and someone
explaining it to me when you look up the
solution to a problem and it still
doesn't make sense for you now it's time
to hone down on what doesn't make sense
and learn about it for example day one I
didn't understand the solutions that
involved recursion and so I spent the
rest of the day learning about recursion
looking up YouTube videos asking chat to
teach me looking up more practice
problems and also seeing what courses
were out there to better explain
recursion I don't recommend buying the
courses like I did because they often
are very beginner level though at least
that's how the experience has been for
me and we need something way more
advanced for what we're trying to do
once you understand how that solution
came about now you can move on to the
next problem again in the first few days
don't Focus too much on knowing exactly
how to solve it but now that things are
clicking we can we can move on a little
bit something that's going to help so
much with this is with step seven limit
memorization with code there's all these
different methods you can include in
your solutions that can help you get to
a solution faster however although those
methods are fantastic it can make it
difficult when you are in a test to know
which methods to pull when and also to
simply just remember them and how they
operate going back to that sorting a
list example there is a method for
sorting a list that is simply take the
array you're given in job script take
the array you're given dot sort
parentheses parentheses as in like open
parentheses close parentheses and then
boom they provide you your sorted array
however that's now another method we
need to memorize so instead understand
how you can do it without that method
being used keeping to the Basics like
this will help you so so so much when we
have just such a tight deadline step
number eight when you go through your
day of problems and you lay your head
down and wake up the next day to do it
all over again pick a problem from the
previous day to do again because like I
said it's not completely necessary to in
the first few days make sure you fully
know exactly how to solve each and every
problem it's more necessary to
understand how and why the solution you
found and looked up works and make it
understand for your brain and then
moving on so the way to really now be
able to do the problem 10 days from now
is by the next day attempting it again
if you still can't get it that's fine
choose a different problem from the day
before do this until you have at least
one problem that you were able to
completely solve because at the end of
the 10 days you'll know that you
perfectly solved 10 problems which is
fantastic for the problems you didn't
solve you likely understood why they
were solved and how to solve them and
how to think about them or at least the
steps to take even if you may not
remember the specific line by line
solution and finally step number nine
rinse and repeat steps 4 through 8 every
single day for the next 10 days and
that's how you'll create your lesson
plan the second you don't know how
something is implemented spend however
long you need to for that day focusing
on on it and practicing more problems
just like that and then move on the next
day okay everybody I hope that was
really helpful if it was please let me
know by leaving a like and a comment and
subscribing to this Channel and yeah let
me know what other questions y'all have
especially as I go through this job hunt
with y'all thank you so much for
watching and I'll talk to you later bye